individually Tate everyone wants to set
himself apart from the crowd says our
car tester I know Dyson hofer the Opel
Adam provides plenty of individualism
with many different roof and chassis
colors and special interior details but
of course a modern subcompact has to be
practical and thrifty as well a modern
three-cylinder engine needs to provide
respectable power with low fuel
consumption we tested the Opel Adam with
the one liter Ecotec direct injection
engine which comes in two versions
producing 66 485 kilowatts we tested the
more powerful version opel says it gets
100 kilometers on 5.1 liters of gasoline
the atom has received many awards for
its design with all the
individualization options the car is
two-tone paint scheme makes it an eye
catcher the roof seems like a Sun sale
stretched over the body consumers are
attracted to the model variants like the
convertible version and the crossover
Adam rocks
thoughts i'll give it open i note says
sub compacts like the opel adam are
conceived for inner-city use so the
Adams turning radius could have been a
little tighter but the Flex fixed system
that opal developed especially to
transport bicycles is very practical a
little drawer you can pull out of the
rear will hold a bike weighing up to 30
kilograms and an optional adapter will
carry a second bike the Adams flex fixed
system costs 590 euros the adapter for
the second bicycle is another 200 euros
the atom thereby combines a high degree
of practicality with an attractive
design that's quite a plus point because
car buyers often have to choose either
functionality or looks
the addams interior design offers a
wealth of individual design options not
only colors but also patterns pep up the
dashboard and the intelligent fatimid
system lets you link your cell phone
with the vehicle
how individual does your car need to be
the opel adam has colored clips on the
wheel rims the stars on the roof playful
patterns on the dashboard and ten
different colors of interior lighting
but to sell your car after a few years
you'll need to find a buyer who has
similar taste on task indeed and felix
and so i'm personally his fan site and
in man's opinion